the leaders of the world's two largest
economies Trump and XI the US and China
together those two countries represent
40 percent of global economic output a
trade war has been on for a year which
has sent shockwaves through the world's
economy now the leaders have agreed to
restart trade talks as Trump promises
not to impose new tariffs on Chinese
goods those talks came on the heels of a
breakthrough for the European Union and
the Latin American block known as
Mercosur the EU signed a trade deal with
Argentina Brazil Paraguay and Uruguay to
slash billions in tariffs this is a
historical moment these negotiations
have been two decades in the making the
summit in Osaka has focused on
international trade tensions but for
some there the climate crisis was at the
top of the agenda the grip have signed
an agreement on climate change similar
to the one signed at last year's summit
in Argentina again with the u.s.
refusing to join the effort United
Nations secretary-general Antonio
Guterres said the warming climates can
no longer be ignored I believe in
science and the best available science
that we have today was defined by the
IPCC reports making clear that we should
limit the growth of temperature to the
end of the century to 1.5 degrees and
defining a roadmap to reach that
objective and that requires a meaningful
increase in ambition only the US which
produces 15 percent of the world's
greenhouse gases actively opposes
progress on that front well at Donald
Trump's final press conference at the
g20 he praised his relationship with
Chinese President Xi Jinping and was
also upbeat about the ongoing trade spat
between the US and China we had a great
meeting and we will be continuing to
negotiate and I promised that for at
least the time being we're not going to
be lifting tariffs on China we won't be
adding an additional
you know tremendous amount of we have I
guess 350 billion dollars left which
could be taxed it could be tariffs and
we're not doing that where we're going
to work with China on where we left off
to see if we could make a deal old DWS
max Hoffman is covering the g20 summit
and he joins us now from Osaka hello to
max so the US president described his
talks with oisin ping China's president
as excellent but did they even manage to
settle any of their differences on trade
they settled one issue that was probably
going to send a sigh of relief through a
world markets which is they're going to
hold off slapping their mutual goods
with further tariffs something that
Donald Trump the US president threatened
to do as I think as early as late as
last week wanting to put tariffs on 300
billion dollars worth of Chinese goods
and that would have really made a
difference on world trade so this seems
to be off the table for now which is the
important word here because I remember
mariana after the when Osiris g20 summit
last year we were exactly at this point
and then things started going downhill
from there so it really really matters
what kind of trade agreement they will
reach if they reach a trade agreement
within the next weeks because that's
much more complicated than sitting down
together here at the g20 summit shaking
hands and saying everything is excellent
when you still have so many problems and
details to solve
well max another major development at
the g20 was the announcement by the EU
they've reached a draft agreement of
what's the biggest trade pact in the
--use history with the Americas or group
of a Latin American countries with the
significance of the timing of the
announcement of this draft trade deal
yeah that was you know you couldn't you
couldn't make this up really because at
the one hand you have leaders struggling
with bilateral rule agree
it's like China in the US and on the
other hand you have the EU shining on
the world trade stage going up there and
saying it took us 20 years but still we
made it and it shows that there is still
room for this kind of compromise for the
multilateral framework and it's
unimaginable that this is just a
coincidence this was on purpose to send
the message the EU is open for business
and our model is actually working if you
look at it and the model of that Donald
Trump in the US and all the other
countries that are not in favor of the
multilateral framework of hashing out
these kind of compromises and deals are
on the wrong track
Maxon despite various differences among
the g20 they still managed to renew a
commitment to tackle climate change
while at least without Donald Trump and
they also were able to agree on a final
communique so do both of these things
then qualify as a success in your
opinion well the climate issue might
have been even more complicated than the
trade issue because as we understand the
United States demanded at the beginning
that the whole topic of climate change
be scrapped from the final communique
but there was strong opposition against
that and then there was fear that other
countries like Brazil might not want to
sign that part of the communique because
in Brazil you now have junior bosun ro
who's often called the Trump of the
tropics and he said he was a big fan of
Trump sawr there seemed to be some
danger there but in the end they managed
to keep the 19 together so 19 countries
except for the United States to sign
that paragraph of the communique and
that does qualify as a success even
though you don't have the second biggest
polluter in the world when it comes to
greenhouse gas emissions the United
States in that and of course that that's
not good for the planet as a whole but
if you look at the g20 and what what
could be expected from this meeting it's
a success and I think you know
generically speaking the same qualifies
for trade there was some compromise they
had to take out for example the
protectionism part in the past where
they said protectionism is bad
due to influence of the United States
but they still managed to have some
common ground there and and a communique
itself something that many
doubted beforehand so yes keeping the
status quo in these difficult times
qualifies as success
well max along with trade and climate
change there was another topic that was
discussed that's German Chancellor
Angela Merkel's health there has been a
great deal of concern after she was seen
having an episode of shaking two times
she did talk about that at a press
conference let's have a quick listen
I can tell you that firstly I understand
your question but I have nothing special
to tell you except that I am well and
convinced that just as this reaction
came about it will also go away again
alright so the German Chancellor a bit
cryptic there max what do you make of
her statement well I was there at the
press conference and you could tell that
you know she doesn't like that kind of
questions nobody really does but by
signalling that she understood the
question she acknowledges that there
there was a problem she's quite open
about that but she won't say if she
knows why disappeared and why this
disappeared again all I can say from
seeing her twice during these two days
is that she appeared to be as she always
is very calm very collected we did not
see any shaking of any kind and I'm not
a doctor so I don't really know what
this means for us what's important is is
she doing her job here can we can we
give a judgement on that and yes she
definitely did do what is expected of a
German Chancellor at the g20 summit in
Osaka
all right DWS max Hoffman reporting for
us from Osaka we thank you very much